hey guys welcome to tech tuesday is it
tuesday because i'm not sure if it is
tuesday or not
[Music]
the biggest question that you guys have
been asking me in the past few months is
what is my iphone case this is my iphone
case it's
so
simple but when you get this it's
actually in pieces so all four of these
corners are separate you get these four
screws which are very very tiny so don't
lose them they do give you one extra one
so thank you guys for considering the
fact that uh
we're irresponsible now i've dropped my
phone so many times that i have kind of
bent this out of shape so i'm able to
slip it on and off of my iphone but when
i first got it it was so tight there was
no way i'd ever be able to do this i can
now slip it on and off without having to
unscrew everything but normally to get
this off you would have to unscrew each
little piece or at least one piece so
you're able to slip it off so the
company that created this is mod 3 and
the case is called radius they have a
bunch of different colors they have a
silver they have this gold they have a
black one and a red one i don't even
know this but this case originally
started out as a kickstarter and they
originally doubled their initial goal
the question that i get from people when
they see this case is what's on your
phone how does that even protect your
phone let's be real ah it doesn't really
protect it although i will tell you this
i have dropped this so many times and
most of the times when the drops happen
it's on the corners one thing that i
think that has actually helped this not
to break are these raised edges right
here this is just something that i've
noticed from being a professional iphone
dropper and shatterer anytime my phone
has shattered it's either because i've
had no case on it or the case that i've
had does not have raised edges like this
so even though there isn't much
protection on this this little bit of
raised edge actually does help protect
the screen i don't know if that's
scientifically proven but it is ijustine
drop proof proven because i haven't
broke my phone since i've had this case
oh so i just went to their website that
was initial reaction the only real
downfall of this case is it's really
expensive i just saw on their website
they have a new arrival it's the radius
ti it's
169 dollars
it's shipping in august it's a limited
edition titanium case so the normal
prices the silver one is 69 the gold is
89 and the black is 69. anyway hope you
guys enjoyed today's tech tuesday i'm
obsessed with this case i will see you
guys in the next tech tuesday
let me know if there's anything else
you'd like to see if you like this video
click like if you didn't like it don't
care don't click don't like because
that's not nice i'll see you later
oh god i'm losing my mind bye
[Music]